Children, first thing I did, throwing
pebbles and rocks. You can do that
across Yeah, no. He even inside the
church. Wherever Muslims pray,
especially mass communal prayer, that
place becomes a mosque.
>> Yeah, that's the way I would see from a
textual point of view where 85%
of the problem
is to be found in the Hadith.
Father Mario, thanks for joining me for
what I want to have a lot of important
discussions, big theme discussions, and
I thought you'd be a perfect candidate,
perfect partner for this for the topics
that I want to explore,
which deal with theology, history, Islam
and the West in general. And but before
we proceed, let me just give the viewers
a little bit background about you. Your
full name is Father Mario Alexis
Portella, and you're a minor canon
priest of the Cathedral of Santa Maria
del Fiore in Florence, Italy.
You're also a visiting fellow at the
Danube Institute. You have a doctorate
in canon law and civil law from the
Pontifical Lateran University in Rome
with a focus on Islamic law. Perfect.
You also hold an MA in medieval history
from Fordham University and a BA in
government and politics from St. John's
University.
You've written a multiple books
including Islam, Religion of Peace.
That's what we'll be talking about, of
course. This is the subtitle, The
Violation of Natural Rights and Western
Cover-Up and Ethiopian
Directory and Monasticism. That's
another book, right?
>> Correct. Okay. This would be the third
one, The Spiritual and Cultural Heritage
of Two Nations or is that the subtitle?
>> That's the subtitle. Okay, so these are
two books. Yeah. We'll have all of these
in the description of the video,
and I hope everyone will go and check
out your books, which I know even caused
some controversy way back. I know we
corresponded by emails many, many years
before. And the first thing I'd like to
start with is if you can tell us a
little bit about your own story and your
own background, and specifically in the
context of, you know, what interested
you in Islamic law as a as a as a
Catholic priest. And of course, also
your experiences. I know you've traveled
widely. You've been to Iraq, Iraqi
Kurdistan, Lebanon, Egypt, Bahrain, uh
the West Bank, Borno State in Nigeria,
of course, where a genocide of
Christians is occurring.
Um, and you've baptized Muslims, um
including, I believe, Iranian Muslims
secretly. Uh so, why don't we start off
uh with that? Okay. Well, um
it's finally well, I shouldn't say
finally. It's an honor to be with the
legend over here. Oh, thank you.
No, um
my interest in Islamic law, or rather,
let me
take that back. My interest in Islam
was uh primarily compelled with the fact
all the justifications
um
why Muslim terrorists do this. Uh the
whole point saying, "This is not Islam.
This This is a misinterpretation of
Islam."
Exactly. Completely. And so, I decided
to take it on for myself. Now,
uh just to go a bit back, when
uh my interest in studying Islam at the
university
uh
with the Archdiocese of Florence, my
former cardinal archbishop, has sent me
to do studies in Rome. I made the
request if I can do canon law, and at
the university, I can also do civil as
well. So, I got the double doctorate on
that.
Over the years, I
was just more compelled, especially with
the political correctness from our
professors, a lot of the Catholic
clergy, as well, the hierarchy in
particular.
Um so I said, let me just
delve in.
Can we say you started off
to sort of believing in the mainstream
version that Islam is peace, that that
was your starting point, and then you
wanted to learn on your own objectively?
I That's a very very good question. I
would say that
the Muslims that I had encountered thus
far,
which at that time were in the Holy Land
in Israel and in the what is called
today called the Palestinian
territories,
were I would say very respectful to me.
But after 9/11, and I went to the Holy
Land before 9/11, after 9/11 when George
Bush was the president of of CAIR, the
Council on American Islamic Relations,
>> That it's a religion of peace.
>> peace on
Something did not
did not register. So, anyway, to make a
long story short, I decided, um because
my
dissertation was the
uh dilemma of globalization,
within the teachings of Pope Benedict
the 16th, basically the moral decay,
and seeing how Muslims are filling that
role because um
we're aborting ourselves out of
contraception, we're aborting ourselves
out of existence, contracepting
ourselves out of existence. They're not
their incredible influence
uh in politics, with the lobbies.
So, I decided to engage with that. I got
permission from
my mentor at the university, for which I
then
was granted permission to do some
courses on Islamic law at the Pontifical
Oriental Institute in Rome, which I
would get credit also towards my
doctorate. That's when I really became
engaged and
I was really seeing
uh the texts themselves and seeing well,
this is not a religion of peace.
Um
because there are three primary texts,
the Quran,
the Hadith,
and the Sira Rasul Allah, the first the
first biography
on on Muhammad.
And um
I began debating with
uh a lot of um
Westerners saying that
now well, no, no, you're misreading uh
the texts. I said, well,
it's so here's it's so listen,
I didn't find this stuff on on Jupiter.
I didn't go to the moon and find this
stuff.
It's right here. In their from the local
mosque. Exactly. Exactly. So then um
one thing led to the other and so with
my
with my doctoral dissertation,
the Islamization, if I could say um
uh
of society, it's because of the moral
decay. So I brought both both of those
things together because what is actually
driving
this problem in our society. Well,
that's actually a point I always
elaborate, which is um people complain
and they say things like Muslims are
invading Europe. And I say, "No, they're
actually being invited in Europe." So
there's definitely a dramatic difference
in so far as how Europeans, Western
people, Christians in general have
behaved vis-a-vis uh Islam from
historical to the now. So I guess we're
kind of in agreement if I understand
what you're saying because basically um
historically Muslims forced their way by
violence, conquest, and the Christians
of Europe fought back and
you know tooth and nail and they were
either subjugated conquered or they
prevailed. I mean that's the long
history of Islam. So now I find it
remarkable that Islam is at its actual,
you know, nadir lowest point ever. You
know, from a military, economic,
technological point of view in
comparison to the West and yet this is
happening where they're essentially
taking over. Just a couple weeks ago in
Ramadan
at the end of Ramadan in London,
thousands of Muslims took over I I
forget Trafalgar I forget the name of it
but a particularly famous square and
they were all prostrate on the floor
praying. It was an obvious show of
dominance and domination, supremacy
essentially. So I agree that I think a
lot of the reason there's a symbiotic
relationship in regarding why Islam is
becoming more of a problem in the West
and it's because the West is essentially
capitulating even though it is stronger
militarily and I guess it's weaker
spiritually. And so it's creating a
vacuum which Islam is it seems to be
filling it. Would that Would you agree
with that?
>> It totally and
the I mentioned that they would with
violence
they still have the violent ones, okay?
>> Yeah.
And still they capitulated. Europeans.
>> they are
basically taking over.
I think it was the president
of Algeria in 1972 at the United Nations
he gave this famous discourse.
His name I can't remember and I believe
he was from
Algeria I can't remember. That's why you
write books so that we don't have to
remember these
factoids.
But he said something interesting. He
said
"We're going to take over
not by the sword
but by the sons Oh yeah. of
our sons who are in our mothers' wombs."
>> This is a constant theme that they're
>> It is. Muammar Gaddafi said it.
>> Right, exactly. Yeah. They all say it. I
I have I have videos of clerics
literally saying in Arabic, you know,
our sons we are going to go and take
over. We're going to give you fertility.
We're going to outbreed you. In fact, in
Islamic teaching
jihad, of course, which means struggle
and manifested itself historically
through violence because as I was saying
that was the only way for Islam to make
progress against Christians was through
violence. But it's just struggle to
empower Islam and one of the jihads is
known has different names in Arabic, but
it can be translated as the demographic
or baby jihad, which they all the time
advocate for and call on Muslim women to
do their role and essentially outbreed
Europeans in Europe. So that's
definitely a thing and a long-term
project that has been going on for quite
some time. Tell tell me a little bit
about your experiences. So you told me a
little bit about your academic
background and how your eyes were opened
to Islam, but now let's talk about your
actual experiences in the Muslim world.
Would you say that it validated what you
were reading? Because one of the
complaints I encounter a lot of people
tell me, "Okay, the Quran says X, Y, and
Z. It's all hostile. Fine, but the Bible
has a lot of, you know, violent verses.
It doesn't mean people are necessarily
living up to it." So what were your
experiences in these countries? I'm sure
you met a lot of people who were
secular, moderate, or nominal, but did
you also, you know, get a feel for real
Islam?
Yes,
what I say the real Islam
um
Well, I don't even know where to begin
with my experiences
in this country.
>> Which which which would be the one that
would be the most telling for our
audience who
>> I would say I would say both Iraq
because I I went to
Mosul, Iraq.
Um what what's called the city
Um
Nineveh, Iraq. Yeah, the city that was
bombed where ISIS was um
The Christian areas? Yeah, the the the
main um
Oh, like the Nineveh plain? Yeah, beyond
the Nineveh plain. Anyway, um
It's okay if you don't know.
>> Yeah, okay.
Um
seen after ISIS seen just the whole
disaster.
Um
But like in Nigeria post
the Boko Haram. And when I mean post
Boko Haram, I'm not saying that they
were eliminated because they're still
very much there. They were supplanted by
the Fulani who are even more savage.
>> the real jihad is to make sure that the
Christians do not get positions in
government.
Uh let's say
if we You're Muslim, I'm a Christian.
Uh we got involved in a car accident and
it's clearly your fault.
>> Mhm. There's no way in the world I would
stand a chance in court because the
prejudice.
Uh how
Christians are literally just
um
sidetracked.
>> Yeah, openly openly, you know, this is
what most people don't understand about
the Islamic world. If you look at a lot
of the countries, let's say Egypt, in
the constitution it says religious
equality, you know, it looks perfect. It
looks like something out of the west,
okay?
>> and but going going to the violent
point, keep in mind that
when they say they cite this
um I think it's the second sura
in the Quran
where
he who kills
someone else it says if he were to kill
the whole world. There is no such verse.
Or actually I thought those were the
Hadith.
>> Those are just snippets
>> Okay. in the second sura because it says
because right before
they're talking about the people of
Israel. They are the new people of
Israel. So basically it means if you
kill another Muslim
Oh, of course. Then it's as if you're
killing
because all you have to do is look at
the ninth sura
uh
Yeah, and this is one of the things that
for the viewers is that there are 114
suras chapters in the Quran and as you
know they're not in chronological order.
There's abrogation.
>> Exactly. One of the last
chapters if not the last main chapter to
be written was the ninth chapter the
ninth sura which is also the most
violent one. It's the one that has
abrogated almost all the others.
It's the one that has the sword verse
which is when the forbidden months are
passed. slay them
>> but then there you have the two other
books you have the Hadiths which are the
traditions
of the Prophet Muhammad. And by the way
when I say prophet I do not acknowledge
him as a prophet. It's just the
differentiating him from the million
other Muslims. I said that to a group of
seminarians
I had to tell them I made them laugh and
I said that way you don't tell my
archbishop that I'm acknowledging
Muhammad as a prophet and that is well
maybe he would like it but
with the political correctness but
As far as the discrimination though cuz
I think it's very important for people
to understand.
So it's true in all the countries they
have laws that on the paper looks good
but then the society itself is
completely built on what you were saying
and what you saw which is Christians and
other non-Muslim minorities are
literally treated as second class
citizens including by the authorities.
Yes but Okay, because it's part of Islam
so it may not be on the books but we all
understand it.
>> Yeah. Because
the one point when you're in those
lines,
you see, we may have unity between
church and state or separation of church
and state as we do in the United States.
Over there, it's not even unity between
religion and state. It's just the Quran.
It's just That's what the state is.
And
non-Christians Beg your pardon,
non-Muslims
are always considered
the infidel. They're all But
there is this so-called decree of
toleration for Jews and Christians.
Yeah, Quran 9:29.
>> have to pay the jizya.
>> Fight them until they pay jizya and feel
subdued, which is one of the verses that
actually validates the idea that you
have to be a second-class citizen.
>> Exactly. But then it's also the whole
point um
it's not so much the Quran that is the
problem so far that there's in as much
as the Hadiths and the Sira Rasul Allah
because those are the lenses to read
and apply How to interpret it. Exactly.
All right, how to apply it. Because
Because a Quran verse can sound vague
and you as a non-Muslim can read it and
it sounds poetic, but you actually have
to see how it's
how you know, the exegesis of the ulama
which go through the Hadith for details
on how this is actually done and used.
And I see that's where I would see uh
from a textual point of view where 85%
of the problem
is to be found in the Hadiths. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Because it's it's it's really it's
really
>> example. In the Quran it says, you know,
a man can have up to four wives and that
which his right hand possesses. Yeah. If
I read that and I'm, you know, a Western
person, it just sounds like poetry. But
the Hadiths and the exegesis makes it
clear that what his right hand possess
means sex slaves. Exactly.
>> Concubines. Exactly.
>> And so that's what that means. So when a
Muslim reads this rather vague
terminology right hand possession,
uh that's in what's in their mind though
it's not in a western person's mind and
of course Muslims will exploit that and
say, "No, it doesn't have anything to do
with that." No, well Their own prophet
had how many wives? 13 wives including
Asians,
uh the the child
Now so uh but that's where the real
problem
emanates from at least from the violent
perspective. It's it's all there.
Speaking of violence, I heard you had
people hurl stones at you.
Oh.
Tell us about that.
Oh, that was uh when I went to Nigeria,
I was as you mentioned I went to
Borno State and I was um
Uh
the reason I went to Nigeria because I
met and became friends with a Nigerian
priest who is doing studies
in our archdiocese and he would come
into our cathedral to help out with
mass.
Anyway, to make a long story short I
said, "I want to go there." I wrote a
book on Islam.
Uh
so the bishop invited me and
uh for the viewers who don't know Borno
State is one of the most violent places
there so but
we went to
uh local parish there and
uh
I was in like in a white cassock with
the black piping and buttons.
And um
children first singing, throwing
pebbles, rocks, even
even inside the church.
Of course.
Uh What are rocks existing for?
>> Because uh
I was the guest and whatnot and so
whenever we traveled
in a car, the back seat, tinted windows,
uh to make sure not to attract any
attention, especially with the pigment
of my skin.
And I remember we went up to um
uh Madagali, which is
um basically just a few kilometers the
forest where Boko Haram their
headquarters are at.
I remember having to help pay for the
military transport too, where
in Madagali, there was this one parish
that the church was bombed.
I was Well, the reason I went there I
started to show the very fact that we're
the same members of the mystical body of
Christ, but to try and raise
some funds, some money for the families
there. And I remember as we were going
up, um
we had the military escort, the some
soldiers in their military jeep, a car.
I was behind the first the military the
car, another car behind me. So, then as
we're going up, um I just happened to
pull down the window to take a look.
>> Mhm.
And my priest friend was No, no, no,
pull it back. I thought, What? Because
he said, Listen, Boko Haram already sees
us coming in.
And they have contacts here. All it
takes is for one of these people to give
them a ring and say, You have a real You
have a big fish heading up your way.
Nice target, yeah.
And he said, Military not he said,
They're all going to come in.
Um and it really it makes you think. It
really makes you think when you're in
that actual situation. Similar thing
happened to me in Iraq my second term
when I was coming from the
ancient uh monastery in Alqosh going to
Qaraqosh, the city
where
is predominantly Christian, one of the
last
in in Iraq.
At a checkpoint,
I was in a car, was dressed in my
clerks.
A Christian Iraqi was driving the car.
We were pulled over, detained by the
Iraqi militia at these checkpoints.
Very disturbing. I wasn't afraid, but
it was disturbing. Let's put it this
way.
And these are points
It's a miracle that they allowed us to
go because and
that's for the passport, the American
passport for them it's well
we would just won the lottery over here.
Now we can have
But thanks be to God, nothing happened.
I'm one of the fortunate ones who can
somewhat relate these stories as opposed
to our brethren who are there. And even
those Muslims who help out.
They're also
completely persecuted, but
in the end
it it is a target because
Christianity is an evangelical religion.
Islam is not evangelical, it's a
proselytizing entity.
Everyone has to become Muslim no matter
what.
And if it's not by the sword, okay,
we'll take over population. Everyone has
to submit.
>> Exactly, which is that's what Islam
means. It does not mean
religion of peace. It is not even a
religion of peace. Our religion. Anyway,
I leave that So tell me as a Catholic
priest and who who the sorts of things
that you're saying right now and was
writing a book called Islam religion of
peace with a question mark with a
question mark, but we know what the
contents were, right? How has How has
the official church or the officialdom
of the church, how has their stance been
towards you?
Um well
not good in any way, shape, or form
because I
I remember I gave uh an interview
um
I think it was 2018 when I came back
from Iraq the first time.
Uh the newspaper La Verità is considered
like um
the conservative
newspaper in in Italy.
Um
and they put my while I was still
chancellor of the Archdiocese of
Florence and that role was very
uh
it's a very cardinal role, okay? Where
uh my
picture of my
uh shut up and they took a picture of me
and I was in the front page. It says
Chancellor of the Curia of Florence, it
says Islam is not a a religion of peace
unless
and dialogue is useless, which it is,
unless the Quran changes. Anyway,
the journalist hyped it up a bit
uh at least with the title.
But has the actual has have any of your
superiors Oh yeah, well all of that,
that's where I'm getting. I my cardinal
archbishop wrote me a letter saying that
I'm causing divisions within the church,
taking a position against and he put it
on against the pontiff, and your bishop,
meaning him. This is uh Pope Francis at
the time? Uh yeah, at the time.
In Rome itself, one I won't name who
this bishop is, but he had a very
prominent role.
He completely uh
called me out. He said, "You're risking
a lot. You're risking suspension."
I said, "You better
calm down, stop it." I didn't take any
>> ask him what was his logic? Oh. If you
said, "Well, I'm saying the truth." What
is his response?
>> Response? Oh, you're causing division.
That's it. That's the number one
criteria.
>> Yeah. Basically, because this is the
Pope's will. And Jesus caused division.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, you know, so the whole
point is that, yes, I'm obedient to to
my superiors
so long as it does not go against my
conscience, meaning divine law. Right.
Uh
I'm willing to sacrifice principles
but not to compromise them. There is a
Right. complete difference with that. Uh
it's
primarily after Pope Benedict the 16th
left.
You got this new wave coming in, which
was already there somewhat under John
Paul the second. Okay. Post Vatican II,
basically.
>> Exactly. Um
Benedict the 16th kind of put a halt to
that in his famous discourse in
Regensburg.
Exactly.
>> Um yeah, there Yeah, for those who don't
know what happened, um the Regensburg
address where he basically quoted
Emperor Manuel II, the Byzantine
emperor. Um and he was actually it was a
talk about rationalism ration in
Christianity.
And he quoted this emperor who had a
long history with Muslims, the Ottoman
Turks. And basically said, "Show me one
thing that Muhammad brought other than
death and destruction."
>> Exactly. Um and of course that created
all sorts of outrage all around the
Islamic world and amongst, you know, the
moderate leftists in the West, including
the Catholic hierarchy, probably. Um so
that's interesting. In other words, he
was in your same shoes. He, the Pope,
said the truth about his He didn't even
condemn Islam. He was quoting someone to
make another point not about Islam. And
he was completely, you know, attacked by
Catholics. So But
oddly enough,
um
he drew a lot of hatred, Pope Benedict,
from the Islamic world, but he drew
respect.
>> That's how it always is. With Pope
Francis, a lot of but disrespect,
contempt. Exactly. Cuz they
they respect authority. And I have to
say, um
And they respect people who believe in
their stuff.
>> Exactly. Not people who give up their
stuff to appease you. Exactly.
You're not going to necessarily win them
over.
But they will respect your because
you're standing by your principles.
>> like them. Exactly. You just believe in
something different.
>> Exactly. Bravo. So they they see eye to
eye, you know,
like, I don't like you, but you're like
me. You have your principles. Yeah.
Whereas the guy who appeases and gives
them everything they want and in doing
so thinks that, oh, the Muslims are
going to like me, they don't. They just
have contempt for him because they see
this as a person who has no belief in
anything. Exactly. Nothing. He stands
for nothing. Exactly. Which of course is
contemptuous. Yeah, and
unfortunately, that's the situation. Now
the present pontiff, Leo the 14th,
made a subtle
statement when he visited the Blue
Mosque
uh
in Istanbul.
was asked like, to pray. He said, "No,
no, I'll just look around."
Uh You know why? They refused to pray.
>> Yes. Because and and this goes back to
what we were talking about which
happened in England.
Um people don't understand that wherever
Muslims pray, especially mass communal
prayer, that place becomes a mosque.
Because the word mosque comes from the
Arabic word masjid. Yes. And that word
simply means where a place of
prostration. It's not a building.
>> Prostration. So, once Muslims um so the
historic thing is wherever Muslims
actually pray, that becomes a mosque.
Later on a mosque is built there and it
becomes a part of Islam. That's why same
thing happened with Pope Benedict when
he went to Hagia Sophia, at the time it
was still a museum, now it's a mosque.
And there I I remember reading reports
about how the Muslim world was on edge
if he dared pray in there.
>> Yeah. Because they're projecting their
mentality which is if you pray in our
place and means you've taken it. And
that again underscores that what
happened in England and all throughout
Europe when they see thousands of
Muslims on the floor floor prostrating,
that's not a show of
religion, that's dominance. They're
they're they're making a statement.
>> Exactly. They're making a statement.
That's all it is.
What is So, did Pope Leo did he did he
So, that's why he was careful not to
make the sign of the cross.
>> Yeah, but but he refused to pray. Um
exactly.
>> He he he's not I'm just saying
yes to.
>> But you see
Meanwhile, Muslims go are invited into
churches where they proclaim Quranic
verses that are inherently
anti-Christian. Yeah. And you see this
is the whole problem if I may shift a
little bit here towards
interreligious dialogue, which in itself
I do not have a problem.
>> If it's sincere and honest.
>> In other words, just to clarify what I
mean, yes, we can and maybe and we
should perhaps come together from a
sociopolitical point.
How can we work together to block, let's
say, the transgender movement that is
literally consuming even the youth
today. Uh how can we come together
and halt abortion? Because they do
sustain the institution of the family.
They they they they there's no Well,
that's that's the ambivalence and some
appeal of Islam that most of the world
doesn't know.
>> Exactly. And and
that's fine. And actually, I can see in
certain
situations where it can actually even be
beneficial
to pray together.
That's a whole different point. Now,
uh
I'm not God to read man's heart, okay?
Maybe a Muslim in his own conscience
in his prayer, maybe his prayer
subjectively in the eyes of God is more
meritorious than mine, okay? That's not
the point. The point is that
we believe in two different
Yeah, of course. points.
Yeah, God is Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit. Trinity. Which they abhor.
>> No, exactly.
Uh the very fact that
we can have an intimate friendship
with God. Another point, when Pope
Francis went to Abu Dhabi, he called God
Father. He said,
No, no. You cannot call God Father
because God is not Father, okay?
Um
this is a a a problem
uh
that they have. And this is also bit
with uh Judaism because there's a real
parallel there.
Um and so I
Christ was brought
to the Sanhedrin because he and the
crime of blasphemy is he there called
himself the Son of God.
Um
the the point that we can have an
intimate friendship with God, okay?
Now, difference is that with Judaism,
well,
Islam, they have everyone has to submit.
That's where the real problem we have.
And
to go back to the belief in God. Yes,
you can say
we pray to the same they believe in the
same monotheistic being, but I guess we
can say that of the Freemasons, the
great architect.
>> best way to unpack what you're talking
about, which is very important thing, is
a lot of people believe in okay
interfaith dialogue.
And they think that religions that are
closer, the Abrahamic religions, have
some kind of foundation, a greater
foundation to build kind of mutual
cooperation or respect than let's say a
Christian would with a Hindu.
I actually see the exact opposite. I
think the very fact that they're close
is is what creates the problem. Because
okay, if I'm a Christian and this person
is a Hindu, well, our religions don't
coincide in any way, any shape, or form.
>> Exactly.
>> Your religion doesn't talk about mine,
mine doesn't talk about yours. Now, if
you take Islam for example, it sounds
good because well, they believe in Isa,
Jesus, they believe in the patriarchs,
they believe in Adam and Adam and Eve
and Moses and okay. And that sounds
good. It's actually worse so because
what they do is they appropriate all of
these names from antiquity, which of
course have a lot of authority, and
that's how you validate your new
religion, Muhammad did. But then they
give them a whole different meaning.
Right? So now Jesus, oh yeah, he's born
of a virgin, he was sinless, and he's
even coming on judgement day. Sounds
good. But they're equally adamant that
he was not the son of God, he was not
even crucified, he was not of course he
didn't die, he wasn't resurrected. So
the main points they argue. So the
analogy I often give is, you know, it's
like saying, imagine someone comes up to
you
and says, you know, your grandfather
that you loved, that was my grandfather,
too.
On the surface, it sounds like you have
a lot to get along with, but then he
tells you everything you know about him
is wrong. It's what I say happened, and
he gives you a whole different story
about who your grandfather was. Is that
actually going to cause a bridge, or is
that going to be more cause for division
than with a religion Buddhism that you
actually have nothing to do with?
That's how that's how I see it.
>> that's a very good point
that you've made.
Simply because
if I can now embellish it a bit
they expect you now to join. We have
this in common.
>> Exactly. You have to join us.
>> No, well you're wrong. That's the Muslim
for the viewers the Muslim
view is Jews and Christians were are
people of the book. Yes. They were given
the kitab. But they
corrupted they corrupted it. Yes. So the
Bible that we have today is wrong. The
fact that it says Jesus was crucified
and resurrected that's later Christians
did that intentionally. Okay? Yes. And
that's why Muhammad came to bring the
final revelation to bring it and clean
it up again the way it was. Okay? And
and it's So how is that how how do you
build a bridge with that? Well we can
let's say
if I can make a trivial example
ever notice
when
you get angry with someone else, okay?
It can be a colleague at workplace or
family member.
You tend to
lose more of your patience with your
family member because of the
familiarity. Exactly.
The defense goes down. So this
familiarity
on the surface level it goes well I
remember when I was in Bahrain speaking
with
certain Muslims from Saudi Arabia.
On the surface level at first I felt
well it seems as if I have a lot more in
common with these Muslims from Saudi
Arabia than I do with my own Catholic
Catholics from the West.
But this closer we came together it's
Well what what would happen? Well what
happens? Well
Well no no no because I would I would
and I was um on a very good friendly
basis with this
uh fellow from Saudi Arabia. Um
actually
gave him um a little medallion of St.
Michael the Archangel, which he
accepted. He was
somewhat
open here and there, but
um
when I told him, "Do you know
God really loves you?" He said, "How can
God love me?
God cannot love me."
Um and this is one aspect that and
pardon if I open up a tangent,
uh but for the viewers know, we have the
99 names of Allah, the uh The Makar is
my favorite. the merciful, the
beneficent, the loving No.
But when they say God the merciful, uh
the beneficent, the all loving,
these are not attributes
to God
because we cannot know for them. We
cannot know God. We can only know his
will.
These are acts on how he responds to our
actions.
Mhm. Hence, these names are are given
because this is how he then responded to
us.
But we cannot say that God is love as
the you know, the first epistle
of St. John, you know, God loves so much
the world that he gave his only begotten
son.
And so,
he we then went into a very heated
discussion with that. And so, I just I
said,
"I think here we need to take
a little pause. Let's talk about sports
or something." Let's talk about the
weather.
But I I also find it notable that
whereas God the 99 names is not father,
he's the Makar, which means he's the
deceiver and the schemer. Okay, imagine
it it clearly says yes, I know. This is
the
how can the the almighty creator who in
the New Testament is a god of love and
light, here he's called a schemer and a
plotter. And
also the very fact
we believe that God created us
because of love.
There's this famous very good movie
famous movie The Agony and the Ecstasy
with Rex Harrison and Charlton Heston.
Rex Harrison played Oh, Leonardo
Leonardo da Vinci or Michelangelo?
Michelangelo. And it was based on the
painting of the Sistine Chapel and at
the towards the end of the movie
the Pope is looking up at the fresco The
Creation of Man.
And Michelangelo is next to him and he
says, "Is this how you see
God beneficent? Is this how you see man
noble, beautiful?" He says, "Well,
the act
the act of creation is an act of love.
They cannot see that because right there
in the crowd
Yeah and and it says he I created man
and jinn just to be known.
That's it.
That's the cause. Just so that way you
can know that I am Allah. The famous
name Abdullah Yeah. means a slave of
God. He's a slave. So Abdullah means I'm
the slave of Allah, not the son.
Not serving Not servant or son, slave.
Cuz there's an Arabic word for servant.
Exactly.
>> it. Exactly exactly slave.
>> No. And so no but that's a very good
good point because
again
we can
I will say this. I respect the fact that
they hold to their principles.
>> do too. Okay. That I will
>> be wrong but at least
but at least they have you know further
Yeah, you know where you stand.
Whereas with especially me in the
Catholic
uh world
especially coming from a bureaucratic
position
uh many people say, "Well, that's why
you see you could have been a bishop.
You're not
I didn't become a priest for that.
You're not diplomatic enough.
Um but it it it's just this is where the
problem is.
Um So, let's talk about that. Why is the
West and especially Christians, I call
them doormat Christians, doormat
Christianity by which I mean it seems
that in the West Christians of whatever
denomination actually, but you know, um
they they believe in and I I actually
think it's a heresy because a heresy of
course is you take one aspect of a
religion, Christianity, and you make the
religion all about that aspect and
uh and ignore the rest of it. Okay, so
there's no balance. And it seems that
they've taken all the peace-tolerant,
loving verses, Jesus' words in the New
Testament and all that, and they've you
know, turn the other cheek, forgive, and
they've made the religion that's all
it's about. Okay. Yeah. And there's
nothing more to it than that. Yeah. I if
I can just maybe backtrack a bit some
circle, it all begins with the Second
Vatican Council. Okay. This mushy new
ecclesiology
>> tell us about that. Um
where
prior it was always for example the
faithful of Christ
um the mystical body
is the church of Christ is the church on
and on. That began to change.
Not church teaching because we believe
that
uh the church cannot
erroneously, but men within the church
the hierarchy began to do that.
Um the very fact uh that
um
one of the conciliar document says that
Muslims pray to the same God as we pray,
which they don't, and they will
themselves will tell you, we do not pray
to the same God. How can he be the same
God if he gives different
antithetical commandments? That means
God is schizophrenic.
Yeah, that's right.
It's It's just because as I say, you
know,
God won the victory with his death on
the cross and resurrection from the
dead, not by the sword.
Actually, which is why the apostles
in
in Acts of the Apostles,
before the Lord returns back to the
Father, he says, "So, when are you going
to restore the kingdom?" They were
expecting a military, material, physical
kingdom. No, he is the kingdom. He is
the new temple.
The Lord said, "Have you not yet
understood They have fully understood
Pentecost Sunday."
But, they could just they said, "No, no,
no, no, no."
It's all materialistic.
The problem now, to jump back within the
church, is this openness
uh because the church, instead of being
the guiding
standing for something
uh
it just says, "Okay, now we have to The
church has to find its place in the
world."
>> Exactly. Exactly. It's No, actually,
it's harmony with the world and man's
place in it, as opposed to being the
guide for the world. And
>> is the enemy in the New Testament. And
and and it's
>> wants to fit in. And and it's
I don't know, but this is the problem
because
and I say this to even
uh non-Catholics
ecclesiastical communities like
Lutherans for
The Catholic Church an incredible voice.
The Roman Pontiff has an incredible
voice. What he can say
can have ramifications.
But when
you don't stand for your own principles,
when your theology becomes mushy.
When it becomes love, love, love. We God
is love, but
there has to be
some doctrinal clarity.
Which to jump back with the
interreligious dialogue
um
there is no doctrinal clarity. For
example, okay, let's congratulate our
Muslim brethren. They just finished
Ramadan. First of all, they're not
brethren
um because they're not baptized in Jesus
Christ. But
this terminology
began in the 1960s
with Vatican II, and it's still going
on. And if you see
it's happening all over in the rest.
Now,
when I went to
Iraq, especially the second time,
the Catholics they told me
There was this one priest who said, "Are
you He was saying, not me personally,
but
"Are you
so ignorant of what Islam is about in
the West?" I mean
the Pope on And um if I can just open up
here a bit of a tangent um
my mentor Father Samir for the book that
I wrote, he's a Jesuit Egyptian now
retirement. Uh
he made it very, very clear
um he was my mentor while he was um
teaching still at the Pontifical
Oriental Institute in Rome
say that Pope Francis got it wrong with
this. Well, he immediately lost
his faculty to teach. He was sent back
to Egypt. He lost his job because of
what he was saying.
>> Exactly. Yeah.
And And what he was saying was basically
that
>> What
we were saying. Yeah, exactly.
Um which is why I'm also no longer
chancellor of the Archdiocese for other
reasons as well, which is perfectly fine
by me.
Um but I remember
when and this is all part of this
so-called openness,
my former
cardinal archbishop wanted to build
a mosque
within Archdiocese on church
ground. The place was called Sesto
Fiorentino, about 20 25 km
just outside of Florence, but within the
Archdiocese of Florence. It was supposed
to be the
St. Peter's Basilica of all European
mosques. It was that going to be that
big.
Um
this was 2017-18.
Um a few people came to me, especially
after the interview I gave on La Verità
on on Islam.
How can we stop this? And
what we did we met with parishioners,
but I said, "Let's not oppose this
politically, religiously.
We found out that when I say we, myself
and a few others who had contacts with
the
uh Minister of Interior in Rome,
the Minister of Interior is also in
charge of the cults.
Uh that they're getting most of their
money from Qatar charity.
They sponsor terrorism.
They had mean the Muslims they had
a certain time limit to reach the
level of 25 million euros
in order to begin building
after my cardinal archbishop had given
them permission to do so.
Uh we were able to at least hold hold it
enough where they cannot meet the
deadline. They were 3 million euros
short.
And I remember if I it was on the 21st
or 22nd of December
uh that
uh
we decided no more mosque and so we were
able to An early Christmas gift.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I I
it was the Christmas gift. It was I
remember I was at uh Fiumicino Airport.
I was going back
to New York to see my mama and my
family. But
that obviously caused a lot of problems
uh
for me, a lot of isolation for my own
brethren.
But a lot of support as well, you know.
It's just I think So you were seen as a
mean Islamophobe who wants to prevent
Muslims from getting a mega mosque.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. Uh or the mega mosque.
>> mosque, yeah. No,
it's just that I think um
what's lacking is um
we have a lot of good priests, a lot of
good bishops. So don't don't get me
wrong, but
what they're lacking is the courage to
speak up, to speak out. So a lot you
would say there's a lot of Catholic
clergy who would secretly agree with you
but not want to come out publicly, which
is actually the same with the general
public.
>> And I'm sorry people uh
we have to make a stand. I'm not saying
we have to start
A new crusade. Exactly.
Maybe, perhaps. Perhaps.
But
something has to be said because then
the complaints come in
after the fact. Right.
Where were you when we needed you? Where
were you when it was necessary?
>> Yes, when they know there are no
repercussions.
I can understand
a father or mother of a family, they
have to put food on the table.
We have to take those things into
consideration, put it into context I
should say. It would be let's say
a mom or dad who's
praying all the time in church but is
never at home with a family.
I wrote me in a very paradoxical way.
You're praying in church, you're acting
against God because you also have to
look after your family.
>> Mhm. Okay.
So
that is one
point that has to be taken in but there
are others that
they can make the public aware
especially us within the clergy. I
remember there was this one cardinal who
told me, I won't mention his name.
In Italy he said well, this was under
Pope Francis.
He said well
if we go this far
Father Mario then the Pope can take this
way meaning his red sash and his
cardinal cardinal sat.
Well yes, we believe in obedience but I
mean
obedience is first to God. We do even
within the workplace. We have to obey
our employer.
So long as our employer will not ask us
to act against our own conscience to do
something that is to Caesar,
something that is intrinsically evil?
No.
Okay.
So, unfortunately, it's that But but it
seems like everyone's being asked to do
something intrinsically evil simply in
that they're being pressured into
suppressing the truth.
Yeah, suppressing the truth suppressing
the truth by
being silent. Exactly. Sin of omission.
Yeah, exactly.
>> of omission.
Um and unfortunately,
just look at what's happened.
Back in 19
88, 1989.
Archbishop Marcel Lefebvre, the great
bishop archbishop who kept
the traditional mass going
and left a structure within the church
and he suffered excommunications which
canon lawyers, kind of like myself, see
the excommunication as invalid and
actually was vindicated in many ways
even by Pope Francis of all people. But
he gave an interview which he was
condemned to go to prison.
He said, "We have to stop this Islamic
infiltration because he said, 'What they
they
Every time they cut one of our heads
off, they go to heaven on it.'"
And oh, you're citing him. Well, look at
what happened 20, 30 years later. What
is still happening in France? In
England?
In Germany?
Remember the the CD in France
where they went and cut his head off?
Exactly.
And
Why do they do that? Well,
it's in their texts.
They
This is I started a bit with a cynic
statement.
You know, I didn't find these texts,
these verses on Jupiter or on planet
Mars.
They're right there in the Quran,
they're in the Hadith.
They're in the Sira of Rasulullah.
Just look at their whole history, you
know,
yes, some of the Crusades, for example,
were um
wrong. For example, the Crusade going in
instead of going to Jerusalem in 1204,
we went into Constantinople
to large nice Mhm.
But
who started this? This in in
Think of a city just after Charlemagne
in the 800s
when they sacked the old St. Peter's
Basilica 846, I believe. took the golden
cross of Constantine.
And they began
taking over.
Constantinople
Of course, we have to fight back. We we
can't be fighting
>> taking over, but the difference is we're
facilitating them.
>> Exactly. And and this is what is very
very frustrating.
It's very frustrating.
But it should Now, there are diabolical
forces behind this.
Well, every time you know, we commit a
sin, obviously, there's a temptation of
the devil.
Uh But this seems so by design. It's
It's hard It's It's completely
>> a complete paralysis, you know. It's com
It's complete
>> Suicidal paralysis
>> completely by by design. It's completely
by design, but
they've
adopted using our um
our weakness against us.
>> And also our philosophical, political
How can I put it? Human rights language.
Exactly. Yeah. They've exploited it. And
um
they're very powerful.
They're very very powerful. So, what do
you foresee will happen if things don't
change?
Let's say 20, 30 years from now, how
will Europe look? Well, they're going to
have more Muslims. I I've been in
Florence, for example, in the great
market.
Uh
I've been in Florence as a priest uh for
almost 19 years.
Um
half of those who sell food are Muslims.
You can't get pork, by the way.
Uh
they're really going in because of this
demographic collapse.
And also the fact that these millennials
do not want to have any blue-collar
jobs. They can They barely want to work
at home, if that.
They come in
will will work And they're going to And
they're doing And they are. No.
And I think here
the church should be Catholic Church
strong house
take a lead once again, because again
it's the largest
Christian institution, okay?
Yes, you have the Orthodox, you have the
Apostolic Churches.
But
the Roman Pontiff
is the Roman Pontiff. There's a lot of
power behind that.
They have to take a lead. Yes.
We have to love, but as St. Thomas
Aquinas said love means also you will
that that person accepts the will of
God, to get to know him, to get to love
him for his or her salvation. We're not
doing that, because we're saying, "Well,
you can pray that we pray to the same
God, so that why should I wear this
cassock? Why should I
uh
um remain celibate? What on and on? If
it's all the same, I can just uh kneel
pray towards Mecca, or I just or Well,
that's the that's the scourge of
relativism which was introduced by
multiculturalism.
And um honestly
if the if the Catholic Church can't take
a stand, then I don't think anyone will.
I don't see any other And actually this
is what one of my um
Muslim friends from Albania Florence not
Muslim
by just because of the region. He eats
pork, he drinks wine, he drinks scotch.
Actually got him into drinking scotch.
So we're very good friends, but he told
me if the Catholic Church doesn't do it,
just said who's going to do it? Uh
and and this is very important, but it's
it's not so much
I
totally agree with said relativism, but
in this Pope Francis also had a right.
The spirit of being indifferent. Yeah.
That's even the worst because at least
Yeah, because at least with relativism
there's some sort of justification
to get to something.
>> Right, right. But this is actually just
apathy. Exactly. And that's where the
problem that we're having today. What
the future is, well
Inshallah. Yeah, if things have changed
Inshallah. Things have truly changed.
Okay, Father Mario. Um thanks for
spending some time with us. It's been a
very edifying conversation and we'll do
it again sometime.
>> Great. Thank you. Thank you.
Bring back the
Bring back
the fire
and the righteous